[Music]
and
respecting anyone
I need to have an intimate
and I promise it's confidential it's
between you and me do you feel happy
here of course I'm happy here
aren't you
do you feel you know how she would react
in every situation I've always had this
fantasy that there's something else out
there for me
[Music]
I'm gonna live mundane lives or do you
want to be part of something special and
unique
you've been selected to live up there
okay well you're wasting your time
because we haven't even been on an
airplane I should I should clarify I'm
talking about you here junior
only you
[Music]
we're going to ensure hen has company
while you're away
we're going to replace you
[Music]
I don't want a robot living with my wife
I want to leave her here all alone day
after day
he doesn't really see me anymore
maybe I shouldn't be telling you this
utility
to act on your instincts
what if we decide we'll be together
[Music]
thank you